[Musique]
bienvenue pour ce premier numéro de
l'entretien politique chaque semaine
nous allons échanger avec un maire du
département autour de l'actualité de
l'actualité de sa ville également et
aujourd'hui c'est le maire de but qui
est avec nous bonjour stéphane grasset
bonjour vous êtes à la tête de cette
commune de 6000 habitants environ depuis
le mois de juin juillet c'est le premier
mandat pour vous au but qu'appartient je
leur précise pour les téléspectateurs
l'agglomération de versailles grand parc
c'est une ville qui est connu notamment
pour avoir été la ville de l'aviateur
louis blériot qui avait son aérodrome
privé installé
elle fait aussi parler d'elle chaque
année avec son festival de la bande
dessinée et ce depuis 1994
alors aujourd'hui sur un plan politique
déjà comment se passe un petit peu les
choses c'est votre premier mandat
vous avez été élu et un contexte de
division aussi de l'ancienne majorité
vous étiez dents dans l'opposition par
le passé comment se passe la situation
politique déjà
écoutez ça se passe bien c'est une
rentrée dans un contexte un petit peu
particulier parce qu'on rentre traitant
début juillet juste au démarrage des
vacances donc deux mois deux à la fois
de travailler puis de congé à la fois
pour les élus pour les bus pour les
agents un contexte de crise sanitaire
qui effectivement nous est posé un
certain nombre de questions sur la
rentrée mais doit dire globalement les
choses se passent bien tout les premiers
contacts qu'on a eues avec les bus
poisson très sont très positifs avec les
agents également et voilà on est on est
l'équipe est particulièrement motivé
pour ce démarrage de demande a donc je
dirais que ça se passe bien mais sur un
plan politique au sein du conseil et une
certaine sérénité un peu retrouvée en ce
moment où est tout à fait en un autre
on a fait deux premiers conseils tout
début juillet on était encore sous le
coup de l'émotion
je dirais même le prochain a lieu la 28
septembre et les choses effectivement
maintenant se met en place de manière
tout à fait naturel salubre et au pardon
quels sont les premiers dossiers
aujourd'hui qui vous préoccupe justement
tout est tourné vers l'effort et autour
de la crise sanitaire répondre aux
besoins des uns des autres gérer les
écoles aussi peut-être alors il ya cet
aspect là bien évidemment effectivement
on a accompagné alors gérer les écoles
c'est surtout l'accompagnement
périscolaire c'est là où la commune est
particulièrement impacté et puis
d'accompagner les enseignants ou j'en
profite d'ailleurs pour leur adresser un
message de remerciement sur toute la
gestion pendant le juste une poste
confinement qui a été très compliqué
pour eux depuis la rentrée qui est
compliqué également avec les masques
donc c'est difficile donc je tiens
vraiment à les remercier pour tout le
travail qu'ils ont fait leur engagement
et dans ce contexte difficile donc
aujourd'hui ça se passe bien
et donc on a nous les accompagnons au
mieux pour effectivement gérer les
enfants surtout les temps périscolaires
et puis après sur les autres points de
début de mandat mais je dirais qu'il y a
on a travaillé sur un budget
supplémentaire qui n'avait pas été voté
par l'équipe précédente
on a travaillé dessus pendant l'été on
va le faire voter lors du prochain
conseil municipal
et donc là c'est important pour nous il
ya eu énormément de projets des projets
qui ont pris plus de temps qui ont eu
des dépassements budgétaires donc on est
obligé de remettre un petit peu au carré
un certain nombre de chose d'essayer de
limiter notre endettement parce qu'on
veut se garder des marges de manoeuvre
sur la durée du mandat
donc là on a eu un bon travail et
l'équipe l'adjoint en charge des
finances et les services ont beaucoup
travaillé sur ce sujet là et puis
surtout on démarre effectivement un
certain nombre de dossiers sur le coeur
de village sur des dossiers d'urbanisme
qui étaient en cours avec nour prenant
au pied levé la ville de butte compte
environ 6000 habitants c'est une petite
commune au sein d'une grosse
agglomération celle de versailles grand
parc
aujourd'hui est ce que comme plusieurs
petites communes à travers la france et
même dans les yvelines ça a été le cas
il ya des réflexions autour de fusion de
rapprochement aussi pour pouvoir faire
la face aux baisses de dotations par
exemple est-ce que du côté de vue que
c'est une réflexion vous avez déjà eu où
vous allez avoir alors en avons-nous
havre à ma connaissance non il n'y a pas
eu de discussion réellement de fusion de
rapprochement pour le moment nous n'en
avons pas par contre effectivement on a
mis dans nos priorités de demandes a
pendant la campagne et des
mutualisations j'aurais pourquoi pas
aller vers des fusions mais c'est trop
tôt pour en parler aujourd'hui je ne pas
avoir les éléments j'ai pas eu
l'occasion de discuter avec les maires
des communes voisines avec les quelque
chose serait envisageable mais par
contre on a démarré effectivement des
réflexions sur la mutualisation de
moyens matériels de moyens humains pour
panier comme vous le dites des baisses
de subventions alors déjà nous n'en
avons plus donc là-dessus mais je dois
dire que bucs est peut-être assez aider
dans la mesure où nous avons à peu près
6000 habitants mais nous avons six mille
personnes qui travaillent sur but donc
c'est à peu près de 12000 personnes
aujourd'hui sur but et donc les les
recettes liées à l'activité économique
de notre zone d'activité nous permettre
d'avoir quand même un certain nombre de
facilités
donc on a cette chance là peut-être plus
que certaines des communes avoisinantes
qui n'ont pas ces mêmes recettes
budgétaires il nous reste deux minutes
j'aimerais juste en profiter pour faire
un mot tout de même de l'actualité plus
légère cette fois ci malgré le contexte
et il y aura bien la tenue du festival
de bande dessinée que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure au début de l'émission festival
de la bd de bus qui existe depuis 94
il sera maintenu dans sous certaines
conditions j'imagine et puis sous
réserve d'une annulation éventuellement
voir même de dernière minute mais on
n'ose y penser mais en tout cas vous
avez prévu de le maintenir
tout à fait on nous avons pris la
décision très vite la nouvelle équipe de
maintenir le forum des associations de
maintenir le festival de la bd et de
lancer l'année culturelle
important il faut revivre il faut que
les débuts quoi effectivement et toutes
ses activités
le festival de la bd nous avons
plusieurs milliers de visiteurs chaque
année effectivement c'est la 27e édition
nous savons déjà qu'il y aura certains
fraudeurs qui certains auteurs pardon
qui vont faire défaut
nous pensons également que certains
visiteurs ne viendront pas compte tenu
de la crise et nous nous organisons et
les services travaille depuis un certain
nombre de semaines maintenant pour
faciliter l'accès limité le flux on
envisage éventuellement de pouvoir se
répartir sur d'autres sites pour
permettre d'accueillir dans de bonnes
conditions en espérant qu effectivement
il n'y aura pas d'ici là un contreur
nous obligeant soit arrêté soit à
limiter drastiquement le nombre de
visiteurs encore une fois c'est
plusieurs milliers chaque année et ce
sera le 10 et sera le onze également 10
et 11 octobre prochains au liban tout à
fait merci stéphane grasset d'avoir
échangé avec nous pendant quelques
instants mer 1 2 buts et on se retrouve
bientôt pour un prochain entretien
politique immersive
[Musique]